- [Narrator] This is
the bald uakari monkey.
These monkeys are mostly known
for their bright red faces,
which are an indicator of good health.
Sick monkeys develop pale faces.
Unlike most primates, bald
uakaris have very short tails
and long coats.
The uakari is an arboreal primate,
which means they live in the treetops,
mostly because of forest
flooding in the rainy season.
During the dry season,
they return to the
ground to look for seeds.
The bald uakari are native
to the western Amazon
of Brazil and Peru and are
considered a vulnerable species.
Female uakaris can only give birth
to a single infant every two years,
so the population can't grow rapidly.
These primates are threatened
primarily by hunting
and destruction of their
habitat, mostly by deforestation.
This is the bald uakari monkey.